oh god it's cynthia  wait really  oh my god  that is cynthia obifuna and her mom  finding out that cynthia's hard work has  paid off the 17 year old was selected  from hundreds of applicants to be part  of the inaugural class of the kipp rails  scholars program the scholars are chosen  based on academic achievement  perseverance leadership potential and  commitment to service each receives 60  000 for college and gets mentoring and  career guidance kips is a nationwide  network of public charter schools 88 of  their students are from financially  disadvantaged communities cynthia who  loves science plans to double major in  neuroscience and human rights at  columbia university